i started as an understudy and neil
simon play biloxi blues and then i
got a little furlough from that to go do
this
movie wildcats and i was in uh
la and finishing that movie and as i was
finishing it
this opportunity i was supposed to go
back and do the play and the opportunity
to came up to do this
to audition for this show right where
there was a character
called woody from indiana where i'd just
gone to college so it was kind of how
did they how did they hear about you for
that audition
for cheers is it just like your agent
calls you and says uh
no my agent didn't uh wasn't the ones
pushing me
it was another actor a guy i knew leo
jeter actually
from uh hanover where i went to college
was in l.a and told me he had auditioned
for it and i should go in and i was like
dude i'm going back to do broadway
because the guys i was
understudying had been fired so i was
going to go
do my dream which was broadway why would
he say to you
go in on the part that i just auditioned
for
like like that's just mind-blowingly
generous to me would you ever do that
uh yeah especially if i thought i didn't
you know if you didn't nail it there
yeah it might have been he felt he
didn't do it right and and so when you
auditioned for that
you were probably like hey i'm on a high
i'm going back to broadway i
got a job on broadway that was a huge
break for you right oh yeah
i mean that's that's crazy i mean at the
time that's what i wanted to do i wasn't
thinking to do television i just had
everyone told me you know when the time
came and i had the opportunity either to
go
right or left either literally right or
left coast because i could have
stayed here and done theater uh the the
yeah done that play biloxi blues or i
could have gone and done cheers
i was inclined to stay in new york
and uh everybody told me uh you gotta do
this show
but you had never seen the show i'd
never seen it
and then i watched uh one or two
episodes
and i was like yes this is a great show
oh that's right you took over that role
right
right because the coach died yeah oh
coach died that's right
yeah i forgot all that whole history of
that oh that's right the show was
already on the air
yeah yeah it was three years were the
people who hired you for the play pissed
off at you that you called them up and
go hey i'm not doing
biloxi blues no they were pretty good
natured about it
he said hey i got a big leg i'm on a hit
television show
yeah i never had that conversation that
was the agent
yeah right that was a great gig on
cheers huh
oh the best all those guys are so fun
was it hard to memorize all those lines
do you have trouble with that no
how why do you listen to me when i say
that i find that the hardest thing in
the world
i was a supporting role on a 30-minute
sitcom it was and i had a week to
memorize it wasn't wasn't hard at all
see i think that's hard when i did my
movie it was [ __ ] hard remember
yeah but you were the star i know saying
that he was a secondary character yeah
but you used to get these monologue type
situations where you have to memorize a
whole thing you know i i always had it
because you developed that muscle so
from the time i was
i started senior in high school and and
i i really
i was very good with memorization
especially i still am with uh
memorizing lines and in fact i i
memorized zoo's story on a sunday
afternoon
and there's some epic monologues in that
i'm admiring of that really
you